Good morning everyone. It's Mark Wiens with migrationology.com in Taipei, Taiwan.
This morning we are heading over to the Miniatures Museum of Taiwan.
That's our first stop, and then from there we are hopefully going to have a hotpot lunch
and then go to a few other places.
So stay tuned for today's vlog from Taipei.
We have arrived, it looks like there's not a huge sign for it, but it's this banner, and it's housed in this big skyrise building, and it said to go to the basement floor 1.
We got our tickets for 180 TWD
and now we are just walking around the Taiwan Miniatures Museum
So far I have seen mostly European and Victorian style houses and cottages and businesses
all models of them scaled down
but what's really impressive is the detail you can look inside of the houses and inside the living room
and see even the furniture and the wallpaper
and people are very very well detailed
We didn't spend too long at the museum because I am ready for lunch
but the museum was alright, kind of small
but many good realistic, very realistic and very detailed models
mostly European architecture and some famous buildings as well
That is the restaurant we are going right there across the street
and I believe in English it's called Old Sichuan
and so it's going to be a Sichuan-styled hotpot which I am looking forward to
Thank you
This is a really classy restaurant. I love the atmosphere here
We just ordered a couple of different plates
You order by the plates of meat, we also ordered some mixed vegetables
and then they bring you a pot of soup
they gave us this appetiser which they said is included
and it said green bean noodles, I think mung bean maybe, green mung beans
and then topped with peanuts and sichuan chillies and oil
This looks amazing
Oh they're slippery
Those noodles are like slippery, very slippery
but that is extremely good, that is
it's very sour
and then it has a beautiful dried chilli flavor to it
we actually don't taste that oil really
but it does has a nutty kind of sesame flavor as well
we got our soup, we have divided between two different soups
this one is the sichuan spicy soup
and then over here, I am not sure but kinda milky creamy looking soup
maybe a bone broth
and they have brought over our plates of beef and pork which they set on a side table
the beef is a little bit fatty, I didn't know exactly what I was ordering
but it's a little too fatty for me probably
but the pork over here looks very good, that one is pork shoulder
but I am sure it's all going to taste amazing once dipped in that soup
okay, this is, this looks like bacon
but this is beef
I gotta go into that spicy broth first
to test that out
roll that around
and I did not want to cook it too much
going straight into my mouth from the pot
oh man...oh that's delicious
oh that's insane
I can feel those numbing sichuan peppercorns immediately
upon eating that piece of beef
It just kinda make my tongue tingle a little bit
and that broth, it tasted very earthy
and very just ???
and that flavor
Oh, I can ya, I can feel the peppercorn
that is absolutely beautiful
oh man that's good. the meat is so good quality,
and so thin
that I did not even taste the fat
it just kind of melted
so that was awesome
okay, gotta taste this broth now
that meat is so good
okay, that broth is definitely more mild
and almost taste kind of milky
okay, i am going to try the pork now
In go into this broth
Alright, I think that's cooked
The beef meat is a little more tender, because of all that fat
but that broth is just
that blew in my mind that how flavorful it is
woah, that is so hot
and that is quite a beautiful presentation
and I will dip it in here, I am not sure how long
and this sauce, there were a couple of different ingredients in there
and then the lady here told me to add
some of the spicy broth into the sauce
to make the sauce
I think it's like a,
oh my piece of fish fell apart
My entire mouth is just buzzing
and my tongue is just tingling, I can barely feel it
and it is just sensational.
I am loving every single bite of this
Ying and I were eating in there for two hours
and that was by all means the best hotpot experience meal that I've ever had in my life
That was just mind-blowingly good
My mouth is still numb, and that was just insanely flavorful
and after, when we were done with our meal
Our waiter was really nice and he was cleaning up everything
and he asked us, and he only spoke Chinese
so I had no idea what he was saying, but
I just smiled and I just smiled in agreement
and in happiness of that meal and that food
and I don't know exactly what I said
but the next thing he came back
with a big bag of that soup
broth from our hotpot
so he packaged it to go, and so
and so we have, Ying and I were laughing pretty hard
because we didn't, we have no idea what we did
we're just, we're just gleefully smiling
with happiness from how delicious that meal was
but I guess we got our soup to go
and so I have a big bag full of our
both of the soup broths
I have no idea what we're going to do with these soup broths
but, maybe I will put it in my bath
and bathe in that, that pepper oil soup
Couple of days ago we tried to go to the Confucius Temple
actually that was last week
on Monday but it was closed, so I think we're
going to head there now since we're not too far
We arrived to Yuanshan station
which is little walk from the Confucius Temple
and we're walking there now
This temple is very peaceful today
there are only a couple of people here that I can see
and I'm going to check out the inside now
That was good to see, and definitely
when you come here you should combine
the Confucius Temple with visiting the Baoan Temple
which is just across the street
as long as you don't come on a Monday
when this temple is closed
and now we're going to head to the Fine Arts Museum
which is a little bit of a walk from here
I've arrived to the Taipei Fine Arts Museum
and the outside structure is pretty cool
made of glass and really boxy shape
but I know that it's a contemporary fine arts museum
and especially focusing on artists from Taiwan, local artists
The museum was pretty good, especially if you're interested
in contemporary modern Taiwan art
and some very interesting exhibits on display as well
I'm still feeling the delicious effects of that lunch
and all I wanna do is go back to our hotel and relax
but we are actually going to go back to our hotel now
because I need some work that I need to get done
so I am going to end the vlog here in the mid afternoon
but I want to say thank you for watching this vlog
please remember to give it a thumbs up
and leave a comment below
and I will see you on the next vlog from Taiwan